with the city 222 million dollar budget
deficit citywide layoffs and record
traffic congestion you may think Los
Angeles has enough problems on its hands
but one problem is threatening to bring
LA to its knees a crack epidemic well a
sidewalk crack epidemic this is a
serious safety condition residents like
Peter Griswold or upset at city
officials for letting the problem get
this bad people get hurt and people can
die from falling down and hitting them
their head on the sidewalk and breaking
bones about 2,500 claims a year are made
against the city from people who hurt
themselves on these bad boys it's also
why the city's public works department
didn't want to sit down for our
interview thankfully the city has a
comprehensive plan to survey all the
city sidewalks so don't worry it
shouldn't be a problem at all it's gonna
take three years and cost whoa ten
million dollars ridiculous number
everybody thinks is too high the idea of
spending ten million dollars to do
something that should have been the
business of the streets department all
along and for which there are much
cheaper alternatives is ridiculous hmm
who's this guy Adrian [ __ ] vice
president of policy at Reason Foundation
more knows a lot about how city
governments work and as you can see he's
walked down a sidewalk or two in his day
first of all do you think about just the
business of the streets department it
should be fundamental their business
that they know what they have they know
what condition it is clearly they don't
have any of that they don't even know
where the sidewalks need to be repaired
they're starting from scratch which
means they have not been doing their job
for the last two decades so if City Hall
can't do its job and the best thing that
could come up with is a 10 million
dollar plan is there anyone who can help
save la from this crippling mess I could
do it for nothing for nothing it's all
volunteers they would go out and
document it with with the photograph
and the GPS documenting its exact
location an email it instantaneously
contractors would bid to repair the
sidewalk problem within a particular
grid area that might have can or 20 or a
hundred locations for that particular
contract what Peter Griswold trying to
do with volunteers the advantage that
has is that it's decentralized it all
makes perfect sense to me more says it
may be hard to implement on a large
scale but you have to stack that up
against the usual way city governments
fix local problems namely writing a fat
check to a contractor so they don't have
to deal with it anymore well the way
we've always done it is we write a
contract a company goes out they come
back they give us a report it's got all
the data in it and we write them a big
check for ten million dollars and
everybody's happy with volunteers they
would actually have to manage the
process and make the data useful
themselves so contracting is much easier
for the street department but it costs
ten million dollars I'd say take on the
management challenge and save the 10
million bucks that's why you know that's
why we promoted you the director of
Department yeah but what do volunteers
know about city infrastructure they're
not professionals yeah you you could say
well these volunteers are not
professionals but on the other hand
they're clearly motivated to do the job
before its own sake they want to improve
their neighborhoods they use the dog on
sidewalks more says these uplifted
sidewalk cracks are indicative of
something bigger bureaucracy run a muck
one of the problems that bureaucracies
have and LA in particular has is nobody
who manages these departments actually
invest the management effort in saying
let's be ruthless about prioritizing
what's most important where the
resources need to go what's going to
bring the most benefit to the most
people and stop doing all the trivial
and expensive and low benefit stuff
instead it's a government of got to do
everything for everybody all the time
always you got to respond to every
request and we can't prioritize because
that would be
picking and choosing and so we waste
resources right in line ask for Griswold
he'll keep trying to get the city to
adopt his plan and they better watch out
because it doesn't look like this guy is
giving up I'm just trying to help I can
be a little bit assertive I'm not a very
good Wallflower I wish I was more
handsome to go with my own mouth
sometimes but whatever